they've come from all over the country
wearing the beads and feathers of 170
different indigenous groups more than
half of those in brazil
chanting and praying each in their own
language in the hope the supreme court
will hear their voices
it's the largest indigenous gathering in
the capital brasilia since 1988. that's
when the country's democratic
constitution was approved giving native
brazilians the right to reclaim
ancestral lands
but they're back again fearing those
rights will be curtailed this week the
supreme court is expected to make its
ruling
[Music]
it's a land dispute between the
shockland people who reclaim their
territories in the southern state of
santa catarina and big landowners who
say they have no rights because they
weren't occupying those lands in 1988
when the constitution was approved it
will set a jurisprudence for hundreds of
their pending cases
the choklan chieftain says setting a
time limit is unconstitutional and
unfair
we weren't living in our lands in 1988
because had we stayed there we'd have
been exterminated we have been hunted
down by the landowners they put a price
on us they paid people to kill us and
ask them to bring our ears as proof
brazil's indigenous groups have forever
been at risk from land grabs illegal
mining and logging
and they say attacks have increased
since jair bolsonaro became president
with him promising to stop creating
reservations and further exploit the
amazon rainforest
they're hoping the supreme court ruling
will protect them
it's a race against time meanwhile in
congress the powerful farm lobby and
president jair bolsonaro himself are
pushing a bill that will allow
commercial agriculture and mining in
protected indigenous lands
al jazeera brasilia